this guy finds treasure not just as a
hobby for a living he travels the world
to unearth the things the rest of us
have lost forgotten or left behind my
name's lee weber most people know me as
the bondi treasure hunter and i'm a
professional treasure hunter
lee uses huge magnets underwater metal
detectors and even giant cranes to haul
out jewelry bikes
cell phones swords old guns saves of
money and even some things that are a
little
unexpected i've also pulled out a bmw
motorbike which was worth fifteen
thousand dollars it was so cool it's
like a motorbike from pirates of the
caribbean with all the crusty barnacles
on there everywhere i walk everywhere i
go i think oh where's a good spot to
find treasure here maybe something there
oh that would be a good spot to go it's
always like opens up the world a bit to
a treasure hunter's point of view and i
always want to go treasure hunting
what is that that is super creepy what
on earth is that mate
oh look there's jewellery
i get excited about the stupidest things
when i'm treasure hunting look at that
[Music]
oh my gosh we got a bike i found some
really cool historical objects whether
it's like a cannonball or old knives
when you're magnet fishing this is gold
jewelry that i usually find underwater
metal detecting i always get super
excited when i dust the sand away and a
big gold ring showing there sometimes i
find these gold chains and other bits of
necklaces
super cool huh this is rare and
stoneware out of germany and it's got a
date on here of 1600
and i love the design of these emblems
on there one of my favorite finds
this knife i think is from world war ii
i found it in the river in switzerland
dove down and got it
awesome
i found so many coins when i've gone
metal detecting anything from roman
coins to modern euros scandinavian coins
new zealand type coins montenegro also
from countries that don't even exist
anymore i found loads of modern stuff
two apple watches
holy moly you like iphones and also
computers tvs any treasure that's been
lost doesn't matter big or small and
just enjoy the hun
some of lee's most prized finds aren't
made of gold he's reunited people with
lost wedding rings and family heirlooms
help the police solve crimes and
provided items to archaeologists and
historians
would you describe yourself as a history
geek would i describe myself as a
history group absolutely not i paid no
attention in school at all i was surfing
every day and now i know so much about
it if i could go back in time and say to
my younger self you're going to know so
much about history you could you should
listen to this lesson he would laugh at
me
i got started in treasure hunting at
bondi beach funnily enough it was a flat
day i grew up as a surfer and i still
love to be in the water whenever i can
so i went snorkeling one day and i saw
some coins just lying on the bottom and
i thought what's that doing there so i
dug a bit more and there was just coins
everywhere and i thought i gotta get a
metal detector i'm gonna be so rich so i
stuck with it and i think i'm just
totally addicted now and it doesn't stop
there
lee spends his free time pouring over
old maps and history books trying to
unlock the treasure hunting world's
great mysteries i hear myths and legends
of treasure all the time and every time
i want to go and search for it you've
got these huge stories like the you know
gold trains that were buried in world
war ii
you've got you know the amber room which
has gone missing and hundreds and
hundreds of shipwrecks that are still
out there missing there's one i think
it's called the madagascar and it was
filled up during australia in the 1800s
we had a mega gold rush and it was
filled with all the gold from sailing
back to england loaded with gold it was
never seen again
still out there can you imagine
one of lee's favorite treasure hunting
methods is called magnet fishing
magnet fishing is where you get a giant
magnet you attach it to a rope throw it
in some water whether it's a canal a
lake or off a jetty and you pull it in
to see what metal bits have stuck to it
at the end of the day i have a magnet
called the beast magnet it is incredible
it's way stronger than i am people say
how strong is it it's like too strong
almost so if i get stuck on something i
just like recruit people come and help
me or i can even you know tie it to the
back of a car and tow it out and stuff
like that worst case scenario we get a
crane i did that one time it was a giant
safe it was so big i've used a car tied
a rope around the safe towed it out of
the car the rope kept breaking so i
ended up getting this crane and within
two minutes he went bam pulled the safe
out dumped it and he goes there you go
that cost me like 200 euros but it was
the best 200 euros i ever spent because
i got the safe and then we busted it
open and sure enough there's still stuff
inside it so it's awesome
magnet fishing in amsterdam you're gonna
find a bike it's guaranteed there's so
many bikes in there so i find hundreds
of bicycles i don't know what it is with
bikes
but i always find them with fishing
lures on them
the police in amsterdam are really nice
they'll come up and say if you caught
anything today and things like that so
because we call them so much when we
find guns oh
did you hear that zap onto the magnet
it's big whatever it is what do we got
here
oh my ah
ah yes we've got a safe
it's really fun when you find a safe
because you open it up and you're like
what's going to be inside of it
sometimes they're empty sometimes
they're full it's exciting every time so
you get a safe you're like yes i gotta
save and then bam
nothing or yes look at this one spilled
and everyone comes around have a look
what's inside
look at that safe that's awesome oh
my
gosh
look at the size of that safe
when you're working with giant magnets
things don't always go as planned so one
time when i was getting packed up i had
a magnet in my hand and another one on
the floor and because they're magnetic
it jumped up and caught my finger
between the two magnets and crushed them
and broke my finger they're so strong i
can't pull the magnets apart so i had to
rip the mat the finger out between the
two magnets and it was like oh my gosh i
went white
lee also keeps a lightweight underwater
breathing apparatus that fits into his
backpack my underwater detecting process
and breathing machines i have a nomad
and a nemo and they float on the surface
and pump air down a tube so i can
breathe underwater they're super light
so i can travel with them and take into
account places that are otherwise
difficult with scuba gear and then i go
with my underwater metal detector when
it beeps i usually can tell if it's gold
or silver and i just dig it up hopefully
it's like a gold ring or a silver ring
or some jewelry or something cool
sometimes you even find sunglasses you
just you know don't know what you're
going to get and i always find ray-ban
i've got hundreds of them
there we go
how do they look
it takes the breath away for you when
you're diving underwater and you you
dust out especially if it's muddy down
there and then you see this diamond and
it just like holds the light almost like
it's a torch looking back at you and
you're like
oh my gosh is it real and you dig it up
and you're looking at just like oh and
then i start shouting and talking
underwater babble babble something like
that
[Music]
nikki is my girlfriend she loves diving
underwater um with the metal detectors
and she's found a lot of gold doing that
so she's like keen to do that yeah she
is a keeper
that's for sure
some people say she's the best treasurer
i've ever found
pretty corny i know probably true though
leah nikki custom built a
treasure-hunting van a camper van packed
with dive gear and huge magnets
ready to travel through europe at a
moment's notice the lifestyle of the
treasure hunter living in our van and
just searching for treasures all over
the world is so much fun
we go wherever we want really we meet up
with people who might be searching for
things it's kind of loose it's kind of
like a free lifestyle i usually like to
follow the summers so if it's nice and
warm and people are swimming down at
beaches that's when they're dropping a
lot of things so it's good to go
searching there if you want to find like
roman coins you might go to england or
if you want to find
jewelry and have a day in paradise you
could go down to ibiza so we just drive
our van and live in it it's really the
best lifestyle ever we're kind of like
living the dream as they say
when i go scuba diving in beautiful
places like thailand or ibiza with my
metal detector i'm looking for lost
usually modern jewelry hopefully gold
australia you can go out in australia
metal detecting and find chunky gold
nuggets out there i mean who wouldn't
want to find a big chunky football-sized
gold nugget and retire on it but lee's
idea of treasure might not be the same
as it is for the rest of us
this is going to be one of my favorite
all-time finds it is a pair of panties
and try not to touch it but you can see
down here there's a ring tied in a knot
attached to it so some girl lost her
panties
and the ring at the same time best find
ever
his girlfriend nikki was less excited
nikki didn't want me to keep him
and lee's passion isn't fading anytime
soon every new discovery inspires him to
keep the search going
when i'm treasure hunting i'm definitely
a kid at heart you know dreaming of
pirate shipwrecks on deserted islands
and how rich i'm gonna be it's kind of
childish in a way but in a way it's also
reality it's the best hobby ever because
anyone can find treasure no matter where
you are in the world it could be in your
backyard it could be in the creek down
the road it could be in the middle of
amsterdam will you ever stop
never i'll never stop treasure hunting i
love it i'm addicted i could never see
myself stopping everywhere i go i think
about treasure hunting and there's
always new spots i don't think i'm ever
going to get sick of doing this